c'est quoi un match normal ça n'existe
pas ça non
oui je t'ai james banger et
c'était ça provoque eu beaucoup de bruit
parce que d'un coup j'étais une femme de
50 ans dans le bras d'un james bond plus
jeune que moi
non
non je veux pas mettre de la crème
n'avait pas de carbonara
je savais que je dois lutter avec
quelque chose et ma personnalité en
effet je fais un métier je suis beaucoup
dans l'exposition est dans la lumière
mais la vérité que j'ai aussi besoin de
beaucoup d'ombré pour me ressourcer
je suis avant elle a bon ben ça non
moi je pense qu on a fait quand on a
fait trois films comme le mépris la
vérité et du cres la femme je pense que
l a pas besoin de plus pour montrer la
merveilleuse actrice qu'elle est
j'adore les citations elle oui c'est
vrai je me le site assure parce que je
trouve qu'en très peu de mots on peut
dire deux choses
on peut expliquer des concepts très
profond
voilà juste avec trois mois
moi j'étais très aimé et je crois que
j'ai monté les marches je tremblais oui
tellement premier film américain et
s'était c'est la première fois que
j'allais à cannes et du coup sa marque
est quelque chose de très important dans
mon parcours de cinéma
j'aimais beaucoup regardé de films
je crois que ma culture du cinéma
italien et français
ça vient beaucoup de ça parce que c'est
vrai qu'il après midi je regardais
énormément des films et
j'ai découvert plein d'acteurs français
de remettre en selle français à travers
1,6 après midi là
dans un film j'ai rêvé d'avoir un mec
normal s'appelait le film ça peut être
10 % et mais qu'est ce que c'est un mec
normal très rarement
c'est quoi un mec normal ça n'existe pas
être normal les concepts normalité ça
peut prendre tellement de signification
oui c'est vrai ce timide
du cinéma pour me soigner
bah si mais
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire quoi être la plus belle
femme du monde
en effet savait pas dire grand chose moi
je pense que l'importance d'être
qui la beauté c'est d'aller dans le
regard des gens qui nous aiment vraiment
il ya les vrais amour et les forums moi
moi je peux faire livrer